[Music starts] [Audio Description - not captioned]
[Lisa Federer, PhD] Open Science is really
an umbrella term that includes a lot of different practices
that enable people to access the results of
science.
[Maryam Zaringhalam, PhD] When I first learned
about Open Science, I think it was best described
to me as really resting on three pillars.
You have Open Data, meaning that the data
are made openly available, that they're shared.
You have Open Source, which means that the
underlying analytical tools and software and
code are made openly available.
And then you have Open Access, which is that
publications, that are sort of the synthesis
of the data and the results that came after
the analysis, are also made openly available
for folks to read.
[Federer] NLM is really interested in creating
expertise and knowledge about data.
Not just in, you know, the research institution
or in libraries, but also preparing the public
to be more data savvy.
[Zaringhalam] Having as many people as possible
- who are able to access the data, who are
able to look under the hood - makes science
more rigorous.
Because, you have more folks who are able
to sort of tap into this data, tap into your code,
have access to the publications that
result from it, and engage in this consensus
building that is so incredibly important and
foundational for science to move forward.
[Federer] We're in a position that we can
talk with publishers about why open access
is important, or talk with them about why
they should be instituting data citation,
which would make it easier for us to track
data.
We have a really unique position, as a medical
library of our sort of standing, to really
help push forward some of the practices that
will lead to more open science.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]